لقد كلف ديكتاتور روسي مشهور
غزو بلدًا أجنبيًا تكلفة في
جميع أنحاء
العالم وأنا أتخذ إجراءات صارمة
للتأكد من أن آلام عقوباتنا
تستهدف الاقتصاد الروسي
وأننا نستخدم كل أداة
تحت تصرفنا لحماية الشركات والمستهلكين الأمريكيين
[  موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] أصبح
بوتين الآن معزولًا عن العالم
أكثر مما كان عليه في أي وقت مضى
[موسيقى]
تقوم
وزارة العدل الأمريكية بتجميع
فريق عمل مخصص لملاحقة
جرائم الأوليغارشية الروسية
نحن ننضم إلى الحلفاء الأوروبيين
للعثور على اليخوت الخاصة بهم والاستيلاء عليها في شققهم الفاخرة
بطائراتهم الخاصة.
نحن نأتي إليك لتحقيق مكاسب غير مشروعة
[موسيقى]
قواتنا ليست
منخرطة ولن تشارك في
الصراع مع القوات الروسية  في أوكرانيا ،
لن تذهب قواتنا إلى أوروبا لمحاربة
أوكرانيا ولكن للدفاع عن حلفائنا في الناتو
في حال قرر بوتين الاستمرار في
التحرك غربًا.